Now, Shannon had just finished
developing his theories related
to cryptography
and therefore was
well aware that human
communication was
a mix of randomness and
statistical dependencies.
Letters in our
messages were obviously
dependent on previous
letters to some extent.
And in 1949, he published
a groundbreaking paper,
a mathematical theory
of communication.
And in it, he uses Markov
models as the basis
for how we can think
about communication.
And he starts with
a toy example.
Imagine you encounter a
bunch of texts written
in an alphabet of
A, B, and C. Perhaps
you know nothing
about this language,
but you notice As seem to clump
together while B and Cs do not.
He then shows that you
could design a machine
to generate similar looking
text using a Markov chain.
And he starts off with a
zeroth-order approximation,
which means we just
independently select
each symbol, A, B, or C at
random, and form a sequence.
However, notice
that this sequence
doesn't look like the original.
He shows then you
could do a bit better
with a first-order approximation
where the letters are
chosen independently,
but according
to the probability
of each letter
in the original sequence.
So this is slightly better,
as As are now more likely,
but it still doesn't
capture much structure.
The next step is key.
A second-order
order approximation
takes into account each pair
of letters which can occur.
And in this case, we
need three states.
The first state
represents all pairs
which began with A, the second,
all pairs that begin with B,
and the third state, all
pairs that begin with C.
And notice now that the A
cup as many AA pairs, which
makes sense since the
conditional probability of an A
after an A is higher in
our original message.
Now we can generate a sequence
using this second-order model
easily, as follows.
We start anywhere
and pick a tile,
and we write down or
output the first letter
and move to the cup defined
by the second letter.
Then we pick a new tile
and repeat this process
indefinitely.
Notice that this
sequence is starting
to look very similar to
the original message,
because this model is capturing
the conditional dependencies
between letters.
And if we want to
do even better,
we could move to a third
order approximation which
takes into account groups of
three letters, or trigrams.
And in this case, we
would need nine states.
But next, Shannon applies
this exact same logic
to actual English
texts, using statistics
that were known for letters,
pairs, and trigrams, et cetera.
And he shows the
same progression
from zeroth-order,
random letters,
to first-order, second-order,
and third-order sequences.
He then goes on and
tries this same thing
using words instead of letters.
And he writes "the resemblance
to ordinary English text
increases quite
noticeably at each depth."
Indeed, these machines were
producing meaningless text,
though they contained
approximately
the same statistical structure
you'd see in actual English.
Shannon then proceeds to
define a quantitative measure
of information, as he realizes
that the amount of information
in some message must be tied up
in the design of the machine,
which could be used to generate
similar looking sequences.
Which brings us to his
concept of entropy.